there are three main reasons why grain
cannot be exported from ukraine at the
moment
firstly russia has taken control of some
of ukraine's major ports like mariupol
secondly there is a russian naval
blockade in the black sea both with
warships above the water and submarines
below it and thirdly the ukrainians and
probably the russians have mined the
black sea and so commercial shipping
companies are too nervous and they won't
be able to get the insurance to sell
their ships into the black sea ports
because of the threat coming from the
russian navy
ukraine produces around 12 of the
world's wheat 15 percent of the world's
corn and 50
of the world's sunflower oil and it is
exported across the world but primarily
to the middle east and africa countries
like lebanon egypt senegal on the west
coast of the african continent
these countries rely heavily on
ukrainian grain exports if 20 million
tons of grain
is not exported
from ukraine silos in the next three
months
then this year's crop will start to rot
and that would be a disaster the world
food programme has already said that it
is stopping giving food to hungry
children so they can divert it to
starving children it is a situation that
is deteriorating very rapidly indeed and
will get
worse quickly over the next few months
if nothing is done about it
the eu is looking at some alternative
routes out of ukraine and they have
asked that border crossings are sped up
when shipments arrive at customs but
none of the alternative options are
perfect
ukraine uses soviet era rail gauges that
are not compatible with european
railways
taking it by road is slow and cumbersome
and the options of canal routes into
countries like romania
also demand huge resources
i'm really anxious i mean
the only option is to get
the grain out of ukraine is through the
black sea porch they have to be open
that's the only option
there is a reason why ukraine's grain
gets shipped by sea
and that is because it is the most
efficient and the quickest way of
getting it around the world